alors comment appréhendons-nous le sujet
des pénuries de médicaments tout d'abord
les pénuries ne concernent pas que la
France il s'agit d'un phénomène global
dans les causes peuvent être nombreuses
et bien sûr très variables
il peut tout d'abord s'agir de cause
dites externe alors je pense notamment à
une augmentation brutale et imprévisible
de la demande concernant certains
produits nous avons vécu cette situation
au début de la crise du covid-19 avec
les rares qui sont des médicaments
utilisés
en anesthésie et en réanimation la
demande au tout début d'ailleurs la
demande a été multipliée par près de 4
en seulement quelques jours
et nous avons eu nous avons su faire
face et puis les deux semaines suivantes
nous avons dû fournir l'équivalent de 5
mois de stock 5 - 2 stock ce qui est
considérable
sur le seul mois de mars 2020 nous avons
fourni l'équivalent de 8 mois de stock
ces causes externes peuvent également
prévenir provenir d'une situation de
tension ou de rupture affectant une
entreprise concurrente nous devons alors
répondre à cette situation en
fournissant
des volumes qui ne sont pas initialement
destinés à approvisionner une telle part
de marché
ces différents situations peuvent aussi
être amplifiés par la pratique
d'exportation parallèle par certains
grossistes
alors je passe maintenant à des causes
internes il peut aussi en Suisse s'agir
de cause interne plusieurs facteurs
rentrent en jeu par exemple des retards
liés à des problèmes industriels
affectant des fournisseurs il peut
s'agir de matières premières décisions
ou d'articles de conditionnement la
chaîne de production et
d'approvisionnement du médicament est un
processus complexe qui mobilise de
nombreux acteurs
d'autres causes internes sont liées à
des investigations en matière de qualité
et ça c'est un point très important et
cela est un point vraiment fondamental
tout le médicament sans exception sont
soumis à des processus de qualité
particulièrement strictes et j'y suis
très attaché en matière de sécurité je
vais être très clair
99% de certitudes n'est pas acceptable
chez Pfizer c'est 100% ou rien